Game of Thrones prequel series, House of the
Dragon,
although based on the George RR Martin's Targaryen
history book Fire & Blood,
will not feature only Targaryens, but many
other houses
and many other legendary figures from that
time period as well.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the show is also the key
in the history of House Targaryen, the Dance
of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil war,
which divided the entire kingdom
and launched a huge war that was fought from
129 AC to 131 AC.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, bothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons. By the time
it was over, thousands were dead.
Cregan Stark, known as the Old Man of the
North, The Wolf of the North and The Wolf
of Winterfell, was the Lord of Winterfell
and the head of House Stark during the Targaryn
civil war.
A huge Northman with a hard face, dressed
in fur and iron,
Lord Cregan was a pillar of strength and his
presence by itself would command fear and
respect.
He briefly ruled Kings Landing in the Hour
of the Wolf
when he brought order and justice to the capital
and served as Hand of the King for Aegon III
after the Dance of the Dragons.
Cregan Stark was born in 108 AC, the eldest
son of Lord Rickon Stark and Lady Gilliane
Glover.
Cregan became the Lord of Winterfell and the
Warden of the North in 121 AC at the age of
thirteen, when his lord father passed away.
During his minority, his uncle Bennard ruled
the north as a regent. When Cregan turned
sixteen and came of age in 124 AC, Bennard
was slow to surrender his power. Relations
between Cregan and Bennard grew strained
as the young Lord of Winterfell chafed under
the limits imposed on him by his uncle.
Before fighting someone else's war, Cregan
had to fight his own war to get what was rightfully
his,
to take the rule of the North from his uncle
upon himself.
3 years before the Dance of the Dragons started,
in 126 AC, Cregan finally rose up against
his uncle,
and imprisoned Bennard and his three sons,
taking the rule of the North into his own
hands.
Upon the death of King Viserys I Targaryen,
Rhaenyra's son Prince Jacaerys Velaryon flew
to Winterfell on his dragon Vermax to gain
the support of the Starks
and the north for his mother Rhaenyra Targaryen's
claim to the Iron Throne.
The alliance, known as the Pact of Ice and
Fire, stated that a Targaryen princess,
the future firstborn daughter of Jacaerys,
would marry his son Rickon.
Cregan pledged his support to the blacks during
the Dance of the Dragons.
Cregan had a bastard half-sister, and Mushroom's
ribald account of the war claims that Jacaerys
fell in love with and secretly married the
girl at Winterfell's Godswood.
After Prince Jacaerys Velaryon secured the
allegiance of the North for his mother Rhaenyra
Targaryen, Lord Cregan Stark sent two thousand
soldiers known as the Winter Wolves south
commanded by his bannerman Lord Roderick Dustin
known as Roddy the Ruin to support the Queen's
claim while he remained in the North to gather
his own banners
(due to the vastness of the North this would
take long).
The Winter Wolves were grizzled soldiers who
rode shaggy northern horses,
wore old mail and ragged skins, wielded axes,
mauls, spiked maces and ancient iron swords.
It was long the custom in the north for older
men to leave their homes in winter
and thereby preserve supplies for their younger
kin,
so the Winter Wolves expected they would die
while marching for glory, adventure, and plunder.
''We have come to die for the dragon queen.''
said Lord Roderick while leading 2000
Winter Wolfs into battle. There is probably
nothing scarier than fighting men who have
come to die.
During the Battle by the Lakeshore, the Winter
Wolves led the attack
and charged the Lannister spear men five times,
with two thirds of the Northmen killed or
wounded in their decisive victory for the
blacks.
During the Butcher's Ball, Lord Roderick sounded
the charge of the Winter Wolves
and their river knight allies against Ser
Criston Cole’s army in the ensuing Butcher's
Ball,
a slaughter of the greens.
During the First Battle of Tumbleton, the
surviving Winter Wolves screamed northern
war cries
and rode from a Postern gate. Despite being
outnumbered by ten to one,
Lord Roderick led the Northmen in a charge
against Lord Ormund Hightower.
As the singers tell it, Lord Roderick was
blood from head to heel as he came on,
yet so drunk with a battle that he did not
even seem to feel his wounds.
Lord Ormund's nephew, Ser Bryndon, was able
to cut off Roderick's shield arm with a longaxe,
but the Northern lord was able to kill both
Hightowers before succumbing to his wounds.
Rhaenyra fled King's Landing after the Storming
of the Dragonpit.
While she was staying at Duskendale, Lord
Stark wrote that he would gather for her a
host of ten thousand Northmen younger and
fiercer than the fallen Winter Wolves.
Rhaenyra was killed at Dragonstone by King
Aegon II Targaryen, however,
but Cregan with his army still marched south
nontheless in support of her son,
Prince Aegon the Younger.
The war continued between the supporters of
the dead queen and the King's remaining loyalists.
Riverlands, the North and the Vale still supported
the claim of Rhaenyra's son, Aegon III,
while Aegon II only had the Stormlands army
able to defend him.
While Lord Stark moved south with his army
to overthrow Aegon II and place Rhaenyra's
son on the Iron Throne, Lord Borros Baratheon
was marching north with his own banners,
but he was defeated on the Kingsroad by the
Riverlords known as the Lads before Lord Stark
arrived.
Having failed to get the battle he wanted,
Stark nevertheless wanted to punish those
who had supported Aegon II. He moved his forces
to claim King's Landing where he found that
Aegon II had been poisoned and Aegon III was
now a king.
Since he was aged eleven, a regency needed
to be established and several lords were vying
for power.
With his formidable presence and character
as well as with his army,
Lord Stark was the most powerful man in King's
Landing.
With his newfound power, Lord Stark wanted
to punish those who had supported Aegon II
such as the Baratheons, the Lannisters and
the Hightowers.
However, Lord Corlys Velaryon had already
sent envoys to Oldtown, Storm's End and Casterly
Rock
to make peace. While the word of the envoys
was being waited upon,
there was another matter that Lord Stark wanted
to deal with: the assassination of Aegon II.
While he had believed that he had been a usurper
and had been riding south to oust him from
power, Lord Stark did not believe in killing
him, but rather in defeating him on the field
of battle.
He declared that all those who had partaken
in the killing needed to be punished.
His troops arrested several people in the
capital, including Lord Velaryon, Lord Larys
Strong,
the Master of Whisperers, and several members
of the Kingsguard.
After these arrests were made, Lord Stark
was appointed Hand of the King by King Aegon
III.
During the day that followed his appointment,
Lord Stark led the trials and execution of
the traitors, sending most to the Wall and
executing a member of the Kingsguard
and Lord Strong who refused to take the black.
Following the traditions of House Stark, Lord
Cregan beheaded them both himself with Ice,
the Valyrian steel greatsword of the Starks.
This event came to be known as the 'Hour of
the Wolf' or the 'Judgment of the Wolf'.
Lord Velaryon escaped execution or sentence
when the King issued an edict
that he was to be spared and returned to his
former dignity as Lord of the Tides.
Cregan married Alysanne Blackwood in exchange
for honoring Aegon III's pardon of Lord Corlys.
Lord Stark resigned as the Hand the following
day and left King's Landing for Winterfell.
''The snows are falling in the North and my
place is at Winterfell.''
said Cregan explaining why he cannot stay
at King's Landing.
It was during Cregan's long reign as Lord
of Winterfell that House Stark's loyalty to
the Iron Throne (doubtful at best prior to
this) became a certainty.
King Aegon III Targaryen granted many rewards
to Cregan,
although a Targaryen princess never married
into House Stark.
Sometime after the war, Cregan fought with
Aemon Targaryen the Dragonknight,
The Prince of House Targaryen, member of the
Kingsguard and one of the greatest swordsmen
of his age and ever in the history of Westeros
and was only barely defeated.
Aemon claimed he never faced a finer swordsman
than Lord Cregan.
His name is mentioned within the entry of
Aemon Targaryen in The Book of Brothers.
Cregan went on to have a long life which earned
him the nickname of ''the Old Man of the North''.
Cregan was entombed in the crypts of Winterfell.
Cregan Stark will definitely be one of my
favorite characters in the House of the Dragon.
An honorable man who upholds his oath to Queen
Rhaenyra
and whose men, the Winter Wolves fought during
most of the war
and earned the Blacks quite a few important
victories in the Riverlands.
Legendary characters such as Cregan Stark,
legendary battles such as the Winter Wolfs'
charge into the Greens army despite being
outnumbered by ten to one
and managing to reach the commander of the
greens,
and seeing a Stark rule the capital Kings
Landing,
of that and more this Game of Thrones prequel
show, House of the Dragon, brings in 2022.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and hope to
see you in the next one. Peace!